you know josuke is a pretty fantastic
role model brave caring and moderately
intelligent although one of the most
impressive acts I'm proposing from
josuke was when he literally smashed the
subscribe button for the new world
review and then use crazy diamond to
reform it as a subscribe button granting
josuke regular Jojo content uploaded
straight into his YouTube feed hello and
welcome to the new order view source for
everything anime and manga and it's
juror time again but on this occasion I
would like to take the opportunity to
highlight the unparalleled majesty that
are the anime openings of this series I
really don't think I've ever encountered
a series where I have so consistently
enjoyed and been hooked by openings like
JoJo's Bizarre Adventure
usually it's quite a mixed bag for me
and I have very particular taste that I
go for although to be fair with JoJo's
Bizarre Adventure the openings were very
a very acquired taste for me and I
actually think I disliked all but one of
them after seeing them for the first
time but each and every one of them had
this incredible power to grow on me like
a festering musical wound that I had no
choice but to eventually embrace as such
for that in mind I'm going to rank them
all here today from worst best taking
into account music animation context
within the series and any number of
hidden fund references and alterations
that occur the only exception to this is
going to be crazy noisy bizarre town
because I do have very different
feelings of grounding the original and
the ad inversion that I think warrant
being separated and please do keep in
mind this is going to be a very very
subjective examination as is anything
that tends to involve music and my exact
ranking is likely to be very different
from 99.9% a few out there so please do
feel free to drop your own personal
rankings in the comments below but with
that out of the way let's begin and
coming in dead last in tenth place is
going to be bloody stream and I want to
emphasize that despite being the last
place of me there is nothing wrong with
this opening whatsoever it just doesn't
really stand up to my impression of
every other opening but what bloody
stream really has going for it is a
fantastic psychedelic exploration
featuring wonderful vibrant colors and
very very fluid movement watching this
opening is essentially as good as being
on a trip it's a marvel to view the
incredible amount of work that went into
every frame of it especially the action
scenes with The Pillowman
because they have this great hand-drawn
artistic quality about them but if I had
to say what bloody stream was lacking
for me where other openings don't a lot
of it does have to do purely with the
music it's enjoyable and catchy enough
but my personal preference in terms of
music is to listen to very high-energy
stuff which is kind of crazy because
bloody stream is high-energy just
nowhere near as
is every other opening and in fact in
comparison to everything else bloody
stream actually seems like a delightful
peaceful reprieve and then there's also
the aspect of animation as cool as all
of the colored silhouettes are I do
think they dominate a bit too much of
the opening and there is a limit to how
much silhouette work will continue to be
captivating human beings very naturally
crave to see the faces of other humans
am i nitpicking here absolutely yes
that's what I've got to do in this case
and that's why bloody stream has landed
in this undesirable last place here
today moving on there we have crazy
noisy bizarre town in 9th place and it's
really hard not to love this song as
much as I was kind of offset by it at
first but really the disco vibe is just
so infectious and the aesthetic is
stunning you could take a screenshot of
almost any point in crazy noisy Bazaar
town and spend exorbitant amount of
times just analyzing the artistic value
especially in regards to texture which
is one of the great strengths of Georgia
what this opening has going for it that
no other with the exception of its
Sultanate does is that this is the one
and only opening that is focused on
embodying the concept of fun which
coming immediately from Stardust
Crusaders was a sudden yet welcomed
shift that also goes on to blend really
nicely with Diamond dis unbreakable my
favorite part of it is definitely right
at the beginning with josuke Jotaro okay
ah sue and Koichi on stage followed by
flying silhouettes all across Mario it's
just such a strong way to command the
attention of the viewer and drop them
down to earth for the more reasonably
paced parts of it so what does it lack
that puts it next to last not alone
actually but once again I will identify
music as a decisive factor I just don't
like this song as much as others it's
delightful but not something that I
would listen to over and over again and
that really is all there is to it
staying within the realm of pot fall
though next up is chase
so unlike the first two we've come
across in this discussion chase isn't
opening that for ghost colour almost
entirely choosing to adopt a very
monochromatic and muted aesthetic couple
that with the rocky music in a spinning
intro and honestly I kind of felt like I
was watching Naruto or another standard
shown in for a second which isn't to say
that's necessarily a bad thing I mean
when it comes to the song I love it it's
exactly my sort of jam especially the
chorus and I love the images that get
coupled with it you know like the ones
that get split into six and then the
tracking shot through the alley pass
Rama's face there's a lot of cool
movement and some nice unique visual
techniques employed that makes chase
really stand apart from everything else
that Jojo has to offer what I did
realize as a result of chaser is that I
really miss the vibrant colors that had
come to characterise Jojo for me by this
time and
muting the most definitely cool just
didn't give me that same feeling I was
looking for in series with this intro
Georgia feels like it's lost an element
of itself to me especially in part 4
which was generally quite light and
chill so I think of everything this is
probably the most contextually oddly
fitting opening but I do still love it
and will also say that the full version
of the song is far too short though I
mean 2 minutes and 20 seconds just is
not enough I always find myself wanting
to listen to more of it and then it's
suddenly over and so now let's briefly
address 7th place which is crazy noisy
bizarre town EDM version yay so copy and
paste everything I said about the
original but delete the part about the
music and that this exceptional boost in
energy is exactly what I was seeking EDM
is obviously not everyone's thing but it
does work for me and it adds a whole new
layer of appreciation to this opening
the sound feels so much more full in key
moments like the very beginning hit me
much harder so personally it is a huge
improvement on an opening that I already
liked but I have spoken about it to
death at this point so I think it's time
for fighting gold in six places our
first foray into golden wind and I
actually think this opening achieves
what Chase was trying to in terms of
aesthetics by muting colors and creating
a very serious atmosphere but it does so
much better the colors are still vibrant
enough to have that true jo-jo impact
but the tone of the series you can tell
has shifted radically from just color in
this opening alone whilst it does get to
take advantage of the golden moon art
style which is most certainly the best
that this series has had to this point
which makes sense given that it's the
most recent but there's just such a
humic quality about it mines feel super
sharp shadows provide godlike contrast
and the animation is ever so fluid and
the song well it makes me want to embark
on a journey across Italy to become a
gangster so it does exactly what it
needs to do and the chorus is extremely
powerful I mean the first time fighting
gold gets sung and the music kicks back
in I can just feel it in my soul a
pretty damn perfect opening and yet we
still have five more to go
so now let's step all the way back into
part 1 for solo Chino sodomy and this is
probably one of the more prime
candidates of an opening that took me
quite a bit of time to adjust to abouts
for many many reasons firstly this piece
of music is incredibly bold in its
auditory extravaganza so it can be a bit
of an assault on the senses as is the
general art style of jajaja which has
this mixed manga and 3d identity
happening the 3d is probably what put me
off quite a bit especially with parts
like the close-up on Erina however with
that said this opening is a triumph of
anime it is a truly captivating
piece with incredible camerawork like
the statue that spins and then becomes
the hand with the stone mask well even
the simplest stuff like deer jumping off
the stairs and it all synergizes
entirely with the music big actions are
accompanied by big beats and I just love
it and it only becomes stronger with
every rewatch and I should also say that
in retrospect having engulfed all there
is of eight parts of JoJo's Bizarre
Adventure I do also really appreciate
the beginning with all the manga shots
like I love the little Jojo count down
they do from Jolin all the way to
Jonathan and how things get kicked off
in this very first opening but moving
along it's time for number four which is
from part four and it will be great days
and I would say this is probably the
most Jojo of all of the Jojo openings
that has ever Jojo two bright colors
massive cast of characters cool camera
shots weird stuff in general and it is
the first example of an opening on this
list where the main antagonist gets
their chance to take it over with Yoshi
GOG Akira managing to break the fourth
wall and rewind the opening which almost
legitimately jumpscared me when it
happened guess there's a sinister click
noise and then a bit of lag before it
all starts and it's all just incredibly
unsettling and unexpected of an anime
opening but all in all there's just
something really charming about great
days to me it's kind of like a
culmination of everything the part four
has to offer and in a weird way it felt
like a cool natural escalation to the
tale of Mario it's very weird musically
I don't think I've ever heard anything
quite like it nor have I ever seen
anything like it so it absolutely carves
its own space in my mind to number three
though it is traitors Requiem and as of
right now it is the final Georgia
opening available to us and it's pretty
damn strong way to go out I'll say that
it has this interesting mixture of
features going on one of which is that
it begins in a really soft and serene
place which I wouldn't have thought
would work but it did suit golden winds
quite nicely and thankfully though it
does swiftly kick into energy which is
the drug I crave so much of course it
also features probably the most insane
villain takeover we've seen with Diavolo
and King Crimson but not only that
eventually Jonah gets to strike back and
retake his own opening with gold
experience Requiem so this opening is a
supremely cool journey across three
different incarnations to tell a story
and I am all about that chorus as soon
as I hear that zetsubou everything just
feels like it's on highest stakes drama
imaginable love this opening although I
do wish you that retained a bit more of
the fighting gold aesthetic but who even
cares reaching the top now and in second
place is end of
world and might I say this is a very
strange thing for me to be stating
because of every opening in the series I
don't think I had a worse initial
reaction to one than this actually
vividly remember hating this opening
when I first saw it mostly yes because
of the song hearing and initially it
just sounded like a musical wank a
gigantic mess the pacing is all over the
place the voices are over dramatis eyes
and why the hell are they just yelling
auto auto auto auto this is not music or
so I thought like everything else this
one really grew on me it grow on me a
lot and as I got used to the song I was
actually able to appreciate the visuals
and magnificent storytelling that is
happening all the way throughout and
then of course this is the very first
experience of an opening interrupted in
this case by mr. deer which was quite
the moment just seeing him silently walk
behind Joe Toro and restart the opening
was an experience that makes getting
into Joe Joe entirely worth it all on
its own and over time I've not only
grown accustomed to but I really love
the song as well which just it should
not be possible I still think it's more
or less an abundance of noise but these
days more pleasant and energetic noise
and with but one remaining I now present
my favorite Georgia opening which is
stand proud this is the only opening
that I loved after seeing it for the
first time in fact I knew I was going to
love it pretty much in the first few
seconds I'm not musically adept enough
to explain what it is about this song
but it is just perfectly in tune with my
tastes and the visuals only accentuate
that especially any time where we have a
legacy shot like the beginning with
Jonathan and Joseph and then finally
landing on Zotero well the part where
this thing is literally go Joe Joe Joe
Joe Joe Joe and we cycle through the
three judges again and in fact every
visual aspect of Stan's proud hits me
powerfully I could talk about probably
quite literally every shot whether it's
Joe Toro absorbing all the characters
relying on him well the shot running
through the cards or even the end would
star platinum endlessly punching in time
with the music and it's just it is
everything there is not a single thing
that I dislike about stands proud to me
it is absolutely perfect and that's why
it is and likely always will remain my
favorite opening of JoJo's Bizarre
Adventure but what do you guys think
please do let me know in the comments
below and if you're keen for some Mon
trésor content then please do check out
some of my other videos we'll even
subscribe to the channel a regular Jojo
Wanda delivered straight into your
YouTube feed but for now this has been
the new out of you and I'll see you next
time